categorize each of the following
statements as true or false if an event
is unlikely to occur its probability
will be negative no your probability can
never be negative
even if something is impossible then the
probability will be zero if it's highly
unlikely it'll be close to zero but
it'll be still positive probabilities
are always between zero and one zero
means it is impossible it cannot happen
one means that it's a certainty that it
will happen and the values in between
say how likely or unlikely they are
probability is greater than 0.5 say hey
it's more likely than not probabilities
less than 0.5 it's more unlikely than
not and probabilities of 0.5 say hey
it's just as likely as to happen or as
to not happen an event with probability
3/5 is less likely to occur than an
event with probability 3/4 so 3/5 is a
smaller number than 3/4 we have the same
numerator we have a larger denominator 3
is a smaller fraction of 5 than it is a
4 so since 3/5 is a smaller number than
3/4 it's and it's more obvious if you
see it as a decimal 3/5 is 0.6 while 3/4
is 0.75 so this is less likely to occur
this is true the probability of getting
1,000 tales and 1,000 tosses of coin is
0 so getting 1,000 tales in 1000 total
actually talk about how to calculate it
it's a very very low probability but it
still is possible it still is possible
so the probability is not 0 it could be
a very small positive number close to 0
but it is not 0 it's actually possible a
probability of 0 means that it is
impossible the probability of winning
the lottery 0 once again you can win the
lottery it's within the realm of
possibility so it's not 0 it's a very
small number it could be close to 0 but
it's not 0 so this is this is false the
probability that the Sun will rat rise
in the West
tomorrow on earth is 0.25 so you
probably already know or hopefully know
that the Sun rises in the east and
assuming that the earth continues to
rotate in the way that it rotates and
will continue to rise in the east now
there is some ultra ultra small
probability that an asteroid of the
right mass or a meteorite of the right
mass his earth and the exact right way
to somehow reverse its spin to maybe
make the Sun rise in the West but that's
a super super SuperDuper small
probability that probability is very
very very very very close to zero it's
not going to be 0.25 0.25 is a fairly
large probability so if we if this was
actually the case then as we live our
lives we would be seeing days where the
Sun rises on the west and we clearly
don't see that so this is this is false
the probability that the Obama family's
beloved dog Bo will gain access to the
president's computer log on to dog
ancestors calm and leave the country in
search of his long-lost relatives in
Portugal is 0.01 so this seems like a if
not an impossibility a near
impossibility that that the dog somehow
will know how to log on to a computer
this is probably an impossibility and
then actually be able to read something
on a website type on a website and then
read on a website this seems close to an
impossibility if not an impossibility
and then somehow getting a ticket and
leaving the country and somehow the
Secret Service lets them this seems
pretty close to impossible so this
probability is pretty darn close to zero
if it's impossible it would be zero but
it would be much much closer to zero
than 0.01 this is a small probability
but this is not super unlikely if this
was the case this means that if we lived
if we had a hundred realities like we
had today one out of those hundred
realities we it would it would it would
be reasonable to expect this scenario to
happen and we know it's a much much
lower probability than that this
probability is very very close to zero
if this said zero point zero zero zero
and had like you know 2002 then oh one
way I'd be a little bit I'd have to
think about it a little bit more but I
would say that this is still false that
even 0.01
hiatus is is still a low is still a low
probability so we only got one true
statement and we got a bunch of false
ones